so man thing is way more powerful than
you think and here's the reason why in
addition to superhuman strength that
allowed him to fight The Incredible Hulk
to a standstill his durability is so
insane that he couldn't be hurt by The
Incredible Hulk or the hell flames of
Ghost Rider and Ghost Rider's hell
Flames can actually harm Doctor Strange
man thing can fly he has telepathy and
he can teleport himself and others to
any Dimension or Universe in the
Multiverse because he's the guardian of
the Nexus of realities which leads to
the Multiverse but the main thing's
primary power is his empathy which
allows him to sense the emotions of
others but the one emotion that man
think cannot tolerate is fear and
because of a deal that was made with the
demon Belasco whatever knows fear burns
the touch of the man thing and there's
no known upper limit meaning as long as
any being from Human to Cosmic entity is
afraid of the man thing they will burn
at his touch make sure you guys follow
for more